K
KEANE, BUT I WANT TO WISH
ALL OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEALING WITH THIS HURRICANE
IAN, GOD'S SPEED,
OUR PRAYERS AND THOUGHTS ARE
WALKER THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
VOLUNTEER EFFORTS UNDERWAY,
FOLKS HERE AT "LIFE, LIBERTY
AND LEVIN" AND I AND FOX
NEWS NETWORK, ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT YOU.
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THE
NATION IS RALLYING IN YOUR
DEFENSE.
>> NOW BEFORE WE GET TO THE
GREAT GUESTS WE HEAR FROM
JOE BIDEN THAT THE CHOICE IS
BETWEEN DEMOCRACY AND
AUTOCRACY, HE CLAIMS TO BE
ON SIDE OF DEMOCRACY AND THE
REST OF US ON SIDE OF
AUTOCRACY.
THAT HAS BEEN REGURGITATED
IN HIS MEDIA AND HIS PARTY.
FIRST, IF JOE BIDEN KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT AMERICAN
HISTORY, THE FRAMERS
REJECTED DEMOCRACY AND
EMBRACES REPUBLICANISM AND
CONSTITUTIONALISM, CHECKS
AND BALANCES, SEPARATION OF
POWERS, RIGHT THERE IN THE
CONSTITUTION, RIGHT IN THE
FEDERALIST PAPERS.
I DON'T EXPECT JOE BIDEN WHO
SERVED IN SENATE 36 YEARS
AND TOOK AN OATH TO
UPHOLD THE DOCUMENT, VICE
PRESIDENT FOR 8 YEARS NOW
THE PUNITIVE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES TO
COMPREHEND THIS.
THE REASON IS SIMPLE.
YOU CANNOT BE A PROGRESSIVE
OR AS I CALL AMERICAN
MARXIST AND SUPPORT THE
CONSTITUTION.
THAT IS WHY THEY SPENT 120
YEARS SCHEMING TO GET AROUND
IT AND CUT THROUGH IT.
WOODROW WILSON
DESPISED CONSTITUTION,
MODERN RACIST MOVEMENT OF
TODAY DESPISES THE
CONSTITUTION, DEMOCRAT PARTY
AND THEIR MEDIA DESPISE THE
CONSTITUTION.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT PUTS CHECKS ON
THEIR POWER AND PURPOSE OF
THE CONSTITUTION IS TO BROKE
PROTECT THE
INDIVIDUAL.
THE PROGRESSIVE MOVEMENT
PURPOSE TO DEHUMANIZE PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT GROUPS OF PEOPLE
AND CENTRALIZE GOVERNMENT
UNDER A -- RELATIVE
HANDFUL OF MASTERMINDS,
LET'S LOOK AT OUR
CONSTITUTION.
THEY CLAIM TO SUPPORT IT.
DO THEY?
FIRST, AN ELEMENT IN
CONSTITUTION IS SEPARATION
OF POWERS, WOULD THAT WE
WOULD BE A TYRANNY, YOU LOOK
AT CONSTRUCT OF THE
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE 1
CONGRESS, ARTICLE 2 THE
THE
EXECUTIVES ARTICLE 3 THE
COURTS, THEY WANT TO DESTROY
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS,
ONE OF THE REASON THAT JOE
BIDEN LEGISLATESLY
EXECUTIVE ORDER, HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDERS HAVE
RESULTED IN EXPENDITURE OF
1.5 TRILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THAT IS NOT WHAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER ARE FOR, AND THEY ARE
THREATENING INDEPENDENCE OF
COURT AND TRYING TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT.
IT IS NOT A SUPREME COURT,
IT A DEMOCRAT PARTIES
MARXIST BUREAU.
WHAT ELSE?
THEY HAVE DESTROYED THE
CONFIRMATION
PROCESS STARTING WITH BOB
BORK.
YOU CAN SEE WHAT THEY DO
WITH INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO COME FORWARD,
THEY DID THAT AND THEY
STARTED FILIBUSTER WITH
JUSTICES, THAT IS JUDICIAL
NOMINEES, WHICH NOW THEY
POSE THE FILIBUSTER, AGAIN.
THAT BROKE WITH TRADITION.
THEY DON'T CARE.
AND THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE
SENATE FILIBUSTER, THEY ARE
ONE THAT USED THAT
FILIBUSTER MORE THAN ANYONE.
WELL BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
TEMPORARY MAJORITY.
AND THAT I WANT TO RAM
THROUGH AND IMPOSE THEIR
AGENDA WITH A 50/50 SENATE
AND 3 OR 4 VOTE MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE ON THE REST OF THE
NATION FOR GOOD ALTER OUR
VOTING SYSTEM AND ALL OR
SYSTEMS, THAT IS
WHAT HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ALTERED ALL ASPECTS OF
GOVERNMENT SO THE DEMOCRATS
COULD NEVER LOSE, NOW LOOK
AT THAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY WANT TO ADD 4 MORE
DEMOCRAT SEAT TO SENATE BY
ADDING D C AND PUERTO RICO.
TO USE THEIR PHRASE, DOES
THAT SOUND LIKE SUPPORTING
DEMOCRACY OR AUTOCRACY?
LET'S BE SPECIFIC.
WHERE DO THEY STAND ON
SPECIFIC SECTIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION, ARTICLE 1
SECTION 8, CLAUSE 3.
CALLED COMMERCE CLAUSE.
PURPOSE IS FOR CONGRESS TO
REGULATE COMMERCE WITH
FOREIGN NATIONS AND AMONG
SEVERAL STATES AND WITH
INDIAN TRIBES, THAT IS IT
DEMOCRAT SINCE THE NEW DEAL.
OBAMA, AND BIDEN, THEY HAVE
DESTROYED
COMMERCE CLAUSE, IT WAS TO
STOP STATES FROM FIGHTING
EACH OTHER AND PREVENTS EACH
OTHER TO HAVE COMMERCE, NOW
THEY USE THEM TO REGULATE
THEM AND BAND THINGS AND
IMPOSE THING, VIRTUALLY NO
CONTROL OF OUR ECONOMY NOW
UNDER THE COMMERCE CLAUSE,
THEY TERNED IT ON ITS HEAD,
ARTICLE 2.
SECOND 1, CLAUSE 2:
>> THEY HATE THAT CLAUSE,
THEY DON'T WANT THEM TO MAKE
ELECTION LAWS, BUT FOR THAT
PROVISION IN THE
CONSTITUTION, IT WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN RATIFIED BY
THE STATES, WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY WITH STATES
DETERMINE THE ELECTION
PROCEDURES WHAT, HAPPENED
HERE IS THAT DEMOCRATS WANT
THEIR COURTS, LIKE THE STATE
SUPREME COURT, IN
PENNSYLVANIA, YOU MAY
REMEMBER IN FLORIDA AND
OTHER COURTS, TO OVERTURN
WHAT THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
THROUGH THE STATE LEGISLATOR
ARE DOING OR DEMOCRAT
GOVERNORS TO OVERTURN INTO
STATE LEGISLATORS ARE DOING
AND SECRETARY OF THE STATE
WE SAW THAT IN 2020
ELECTION, THAT IS WHAT THEY
DID.
A CASE OUT OF NORTH CAROLINA
IS NOW BUYING BROUGHT TO
U.S. SUPREME COURT, AND
DEMOCRAT PARTY IS FURIOUS
WITH THIS CASE, AND TRYING
TO INTIMIDATE THE JUSTICE TO
RULE AGAINST NORTH CAROLINA.
LET'S LOOK AT ARTICLE 2,
SECTION 1 CLAUSE 3.
ELECT -- ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
WANTS TO KILL IT AND REPLACE
IT WITH A DIRECT NATIONAL
VOTE FOR PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT, THAT MEANS
BIG CITIES AND POPULATED
POPULATE BLUE STATES
WOULD CONTROL THE COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW.
ALL THE REST, ALL THESE
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS THEY WILL
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO SAY IN
THE GOVERNING OF THIS
NATION, THEY WANT TO TAKE
THE PROCESS OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE AND WAY IT WAS SET
UP AND ELIMINATE IT AGAIN.
AS A POWER GRAB, DOES THAT
SOUND LIKE THEY ARE FOR THE
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT?
NO.
LET'S LOOK AT ARTICLE 2,
SECOND 3.
DEFIED EVERY IMMIGRATION LAW
IN VIOLATION OF ARTICLE 2
SECOND SECTION 3.
THEY WOULD BLOWOUT 4
SECTIONS OF UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION.
JUST BLOW THEM OUT.
AND SO, THIS IS WHERE THEY
STAND, LET'S LOOK AT ARTICLE
6 CLAUSE 2.
SYSTEM REMESY CLAUSE, STATES
ARE BOUND CONSTITUTIONALLY.
BY LEGITIMATE FEDERAL LAWS,
THEY ARE FOUND, THE
SANCTUARY CITIES AND
SANITARY STATES ARE
VIOLATING THE CONSTITUTION
BY NULLIFYING THE
CONFEDERACY LAWS.
NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE TO
STOP THEM EXCEPT FOR RON
DESANTIS AND ABBOTT.
ABBOTT.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE FREE
SPEECH ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
AND ASK A BAKER WHO IS AN
CHRISTIAN, IF THEY DECIDE
WHO THEY CAN OR CANNOT BAKE
CAKES OR DELIVER TO.
AND RIGHT TO PEACEFUL
PROTEST SOUTH THE WINDOW,
THEY ARE ROUNDING UP PEOPLE
WHO WERE PEACEFUL PROTESTING
ON JANUARY 6, I'M NOT
TALKING VIOLENCE BUT THOSE
WHO ARE PEACEFUL PROTESTS,
SECOND AMENDMENT, RIGHT TO
BEAR ARMS, UNDER CONSTANT
ATTACK BY THE DEMOCRACIES.
TO DISARM YOU.
TO SEPARATE YOU FROM
WEAPONS, THERE IT IS IN THE
BILL OF RIGHTS, FIFTH
AMENDMENT, DUE PROCESS
CLAUSE.
EXERCISES YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS ARE UNDER
CONSTANT ATTACK, YOU SHOULD
BE DENY THE RIGHT TO OWN A
WEAPON UNDER A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT REASONS RIGHT?
>> AND 10 AMENDMENT.
FEDERAL, THE DEMOCRAT DOWN
BELIEVE IN FEDERALISM, THEY
BELIEVE IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS WHY THEY HATE THE
DOBBS DECISION THAT IS A
FEDERALISM DECISION WHERE
THE STATES MAKE UP THEIR
MINDS.
THEY HATE THAT.
UNLESS THEY CAN USE IT TO
THEIR ADVANTAGE.
LIKE IN CALIFORNIA, AND
ELSEWHERE OTHERWISE THEY
WANT A CENTRALIZED
GOVERNMENT.
120 YEARS AGO.
THE SO-CALLED PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT WAS BORN OUT OF
MARXISM.
ONE OF MEN THAT LED EFFORT
WAS WOODROW WILSON, HE HATED
THE CONSTITUTION AND TALKED
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION AS A
SINGLE ORGANISM
ORGANIC HOLE.
ABOUT NATURE OF LAW AND LAW
OF NATURE AND SO
FORTH, HE SAID THAT IS OLD
THINKING.
AND FDR FELT THE SAME WAY,
AND OBAMA AND BIDEN THINK
THE SAME WAY THEY HAVE
CONTEMPT FOR THE
CONSTITUTION IT PLACES
LIMITS ON THEIR POWER.
THE DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
FEEL THE SAME.
FOR ANY LEADING DEMOCRAT TO
SAY THAT CHOICE IS BETWEEN
DEMOCRACY AND AUTOCRACY, NO.
THE CHOICE IS BETWEEN
LIBERTY AND TYRANNY,
REPUBLICANISM AND CENTRAL
ISM, WE STAND TO THE SIDE OF
LIBERTY, THEY STAND ON
SIDE OF TYRANNY OF DAY.
EVERY DAY CONGRESS MEETS,
EVERY DEBUTED -- BIDEN
IS IN OFFI